under my leadership the Conservative
Party will put itself completely
absolutely unequivocally at the service
of ordinary working people Theresa May
is the last woman standing after
everyone else imploded she's done what
she does best which is to stick to doing
the job in front of her she's not
somebody with runaway charisma like
Boris Johnson she's not somebody who's
focused on the next political
calculation like George Osborne and
she's not someone who's filled with
ideological zeal like Michael Gove
instead she is in many ways Britain's
top pragmatist May is Britain's second
woman Prime Minister and it's inevitable
that she's going to be compared with the
first Margaret Thatcher that's a
comparison that may another Tory another
tough woman is going to be quite happy
with brexit means brexit and we are
going to make a success of it the big
question for the next prime minister is
when do you trigger article 50 of the
Lisbon Treaty the thing that begins two
years of intense negotiations Teresa
Mays pitch has been let's slow
everything down and she said definitely
not this year are you gonna stand Home
Secretary oh I think the first thing
she's going to do is look to build
alliances in Europe and crucially she's
going to try and form an alliance with a
woman who in many ways has a similar
background a similar pedigree another
clergyman's daughter the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel Teresa mayors
set to brexit goals one is to secure as
much access as possible to the single
market and the other is to end the free
movement of European citizens in and out
of the UK the problem is that for
European leaders those two things are
indivisible so there you have the
unstoppable force and the immovable
object of British brexit negotiations